to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance
Le concerts
distinguished members of the security
Council
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
since the last briefing by the higher
representative for disarmament affairs
to the security Council
on the topic of transfers of military
assets to Ukraine in February this year
the provision of military assistance
to the Armed Forces
of Ukraine has continued
information from governments
about
their transfers of weapon systems
and ammunition is available in open
sources
these transfers
have included
heavy Conventional Weapons including
battle tanks
armored combat vehicles
combat aircraft
helicopters
large caliber artillery systems
missile systems and on crude combat
aerial Vehicles as well as remotely
operated Munitions and small arms and
light weapons
they have also been reports of States
transferring or planning to transfer
weapons
such as on crude combat aerial vehicles
and ammunition
to the Russian Armed Forces for use in
Ukraine
moreover
media Outlets have reported on the
transfer of major conventional arms
including artillery rocket systems
to non-state groups involved in the war
in Ukraine
the large-scale influx of weapons and
ammunition into any situation of armed
conflict
raises concerns for peace security and
stability
including as a result of diversion
measures to address the risk of
diversion to unauthorized end users
and for on Earth authorized uses are
essential to prevent further instability
and insecurity in Ukraine in the region
and Beyond
such measures include pre-
transfer risk assessment
and user certification
effective legal and enforcement measures
and post shipment verifications such as
on-site inspections
diversion prevention also requires
cooperation and information exchange
between importing Transit and exporting
States as well as concrete measures such
as marking and tracing
effective accounting practices and
physical safeguarding of arms and
ammunition as well as Customs and Border
control measures
the United Nations register
of conventional arms on Roka
remains a key tool in this regard
transparency in armaments can serve as a
confidence building measure
thereby contributing to the prevention
and reduction of misperceptions and
tensions among member states
in his 30 years of operation
a hundred and seventy eight member
states have submitted a report to Anoka
at least once
I call upon member states to participate
in this mechanism
in this mechanism including because it
helps to track the influx of weapons in
Conflict zones
to prevent the diversion of conventional
arms and regulate the international arms
trade
states have also established a number of
Arms Control treaties and instruments
this includes the amp Street treaty
the Firearms protocol
the program of action on small arms and
light weapons and its International
tracing instrument
moreover
member states are in the process of
elaborating a new
Global framework
for through-life conventional ammunition
management
I call on states to consider joining
relevant treaties and to implement their
legal obligations and political
commitments under conventional Arms
Control Instruments to which they are
party
in order to minimize the risk of
diversion of arms and ammunition
Madam president
Beyond addressing arms transfers
all arms to the conflict
all practice to the conflict sorry have
a duty
to protect civilians in armed conflict
and to ensure compliance with applicable
international law including an
especially International humanitarian
law
since 24 February 2022
the office of the higher commissioner
for human rights has recorded 23
821 civilian casualties in Ukraine
eight thousand
836 killed and 14
000.
985 injured
with the actual figures likely to be
considerably higher
most of the civilian deaths and injuries
continue to be caused by the use of
explosive weapons with wide area effects
including attacks by heavy artillery
tanks multiple launch rocket systems
missiles and airstrikes
after almost 15 months of the Russian
federation's military offensive into
Ukraine
suffering
loss displacement and destruction
continue to form parts of an unbearable
routine
in addition to the thousands of
civilians killed and injured
the destruction of essential critical
infrastructure and services is
particularly alarming
homes
schools roads and bridges
have been destroyed and damaged
attacks on energy infrastructure have
interrupted power
Heating
drinking water supply and sewage
facilities as well as mobile and
internet communications
hospitals and health facilities have
been attacked
killing and injuring health care workers
and disrupting essential services
explosive remnants of War have resulted
in widespread land contamination
rendering land unusable for agriculture
while impeding the movement of people
under International humanitarian law
combatant must not direct attacks
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure
and must take all feasible precautions
in the conduct of military operations to
avoid
or at least minimize
incidental loss of civilian life
injury to civilians and damage to
civilian objects
attacks against civilians and civilian
infrastructure must stop
I take this opportunity to call on all
member states
to support and to effectively implement
the political Declaration on
strengthening
the protection of civilians from the
humanitarian consequences arising from
the use of explosive weapons in
populated areas which was adopted in
November 2022
this declaration is an important tool to
better protect civilians from the
increasing urbanization of armed
conflict
Madam president
distinguished members of the security
Council
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
which is a violation of international
law
including the charter of the United
Nations
is causing massive suffering and
devastation
to Ukraine and its people
the world cannot afford for this world
to continue
I appeal to all member states to make
every effort for peace
the United Nations stands ready
to support all genuine efforts to that
end I thank you very much for your
attention
[Music]
those council members who wish foreign
in order to achieve peace foreign
strategic
[Music]
foreign
training are also prevent everybody
and the fate of the population is
illustrated by the decision of London to
provide Kiev with depleted uranium
environment of human health
forces
in 1999
[Music]
is
since 2014.
civilian casualties
but they never mentioned these Cities
Washington provided missile systems
provision of coordinates by the American
Military
direct violation of international
treaties and obligations pertaining to
the provisions of military equipment
is something that other countries and
different regions of the world have
called foreign
[Music]
as a result
necessary measures to neutralize a
threat to its own security and the aims
of its special military operation will
be fulfilled thank you for your
attention
representative of Ghana
I thank you madam president
I thank the deputy to the high
representative for disarmament Affairs
for his briefing
at the outset let me reaffirm Garners
unwavering commitment to the sovereignty
political Independence and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine and its inherent
right to self-defense and Shrine in
article 51 of the United Nations Charter
while the use of force has long been
outlawed by customer law the framers of
the charter of the United Nations
rightly asserted the rights of states to
individual or Collective defense when
armed attack occurs
this is the legitimate Endeavor which
has engaged the resources of Ukraine for
close to 16 months now
we believe strongly that The Sovereign
rights and interests of Ukraine can best
be assured in the context of peace and
never through a brutal war that has now
resulted in more than 23 000 civilian
casualties and left the cities and towns
in Ruins
it is only in the context of relative
peace that the compounding disputes
between the two neighboring countries
can be effectively resolved
and resolved in accordance with the
tenets of international law and in the
spirit of the charter of the United
Nations
the fact is that arms proliferation
especially in Conflict areas poses a
serious threat to International Peace
and security including the risk of
escalation and the diversion of arms to
unintended destinations or recipients
we in Africa are unfortunately familiar
and still grappling with the
consequences of the influx of Arms from
other regions into the continent
especially in the Sahel region where
insurgent and undesirable elements are
being equipped in the perpetuation of
their destabilizing activities
we therefore strongly reassert the need
for transparency and accountability
through effective tracing and monitoring
mechanisms which would ensure that all
arms Supply to Ukraine serve their
intended purpose
we urge strict compliance with
International non-proliferation
Arrangements including the arm straight
treaty the United Nations register of
conventional arms the European common
position on arms exports and other
relevant National regulations
Arms Control measures especially in the
context of the war on Ukraine would help
to assert any concerns and provide
Assurance on mitigation efforts against
post-conflict and illegal proliferation
unfortunately the real burden couriers
for the wide-ranging missiles and other
lethal weapons targeted at several parts
of Ukraine are the men women and
children whose only chance of possible
Escape are the Bonkers where we are told
they are seeking refuge for several days
and weeks at a time
with the hostility still ongoing we're
compelled to underscore once more the
responsibility of Warring parties under
International humanitarian law and
international human right laws to
protect civilians and civilian
infrastructure from deliberate harm and
destruction
we also stress the obligation of the
parties to act in accordance with the
humanitarian principles of necessity
distinction and proportionality to avoid
further breaches of international law
but also to save innocent lives
as a collective the conscience of the
International Community must be awakened
to the Colossal risk associated with the
elevated military expenditure recorded
globally and for the plugs to be pulled
while we still have control over the
situation
we are also concerned by the contrast
with development funding in a
post-pandemic era where most if not all
states are faced with stifling economic
and fiscal challenges
these shared concerns should spare our
Collective peace efforts to help end the
war and revise the tides of the global
tri-crisis of food energy and fuel that
is now appending our shared Ambitions
for peace and sustainable development
Madam President we remain profoundly
concerned that the military posturing
and further militarization of the
conflict between the Russian Federation
and Ukraine is crowding out the
prospects of a diplomatic solution which
is now overdue
we however remain confident that the
tools of diplomacy and dialogue offer
the best chances of a comprehensive
political settlement and that is why we
continue to urge international support
in that direction
we further urge the two sides to commit
to a political settlement in their
mutual interest and in The Wider
interest of the global community
we emphasize the need for all peace
efforts to be carried out with due
regard to international law and the
purposes and values of the charter of
the United Nations to ensure durability
lastly we reiterate the many calls which
have been made to the Russian Federation
to respect the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of its neighboring
country and to end its war of aggression
by the immediate and unconditional
withdrawal of its troops from the
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine I thank you
thank you president
I thank the deputy to the high
representative Mr Ibo for his briefing
let me start by reminding ourselves why
we are having this discussion today
a permanent member of this Council
that is violating international law has
called the meeting to condemn those who
support the victim of their attack
it is the same country that it has
invaded a member of the UN the sovereign
state
it is deliberately targeting civilians
and civil infrastructure
it is importing missiles weapons and
drones including by violating U.N
security Council resolutions
has declared its intention to transfer
tactical nuclear weapons to a
neighboring country undermining the
architecture of nuclear disarmament
therefore this meeting is yet another
attempt in the same vein of what we have
seen since February last year
president
there is only one reality one truth
Russia is the aggressor
and Ukraine is trying to defend itself
Ukraine has asked for help and it is our
and we think everyone's moral duty to
support them to defend their freedom to
protect our shared norms and values
against aggression and accession and
atrocities
the military support it is receiving it
complies with transparency and equality
in accordance with article 51 of the U.N
Charter
we welcome the commitment of the
Ukrainian government to use the weapons
only within the borders of Ukraine and
appreciate the commitments of national
institutions to properly manage and
control them
in contrast Russia is transferring
illegally arms from Iran and North Korea
in violation of the security Council
resolutions specifically paragraph 4 nxp
of the U.N security Council resolution
Russia uses these weapons to attack
civilians and civilian infrastructure
throughout Ukraine
president this week the summit of the
Council of Europe approved the
establishment of the register of damage
which will document the damages
resulting from Russia's brutal war
against Ukraine
this is an historic decision it is one
of the first legally binding decisions
to hold Russia accountable
for its brutal military aggression and
it paves the way towards a future
International comprehensive compensation
mechanism for the victims of that of the
aggression
the accountability process should be
part of every diplomatic solution aiming
adjust and comprehensive peace
settlement the peace efforts should be
fully in line with the U.N Charter and
the ga resolution adopted earlier this
year
also the extension of the Black Sea
grain Initiative for the 60 days
achieved yesterday is a good news
as part of the global response for
humanitarian purposes
Albania commands a strong engagement and
substantial mediation role of the United
Nations and the Republic of Turkey in
this important process president
let me conclude by repeating our call
that if Russia takes seriously the peace
talks it should start by putting an
immediate end to this war withdraw its
troops and respect the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its International recognized borders I
thank you America
thank you madam president
we also thank the deputy to the high
representative for disarmament Affairs
Mr ebo
for his informative briefing
and I welcome Ukraine's participation at
today's meeting
the development of security and defense
capabilities
is integral
to the right of self-defense
engaging in such activities also comes
with certain risks and responsibilities
to mitigate those risks
for instance
poorly managed weapons stockpiles and
supplies can be diverted to terrorist
groups or other
malign actors
it is critical to guard against such
risks
we have seen how illicit weapons
transfers to such groups were behind the
proliferation of violence and numerous
attacks against civilians
and undermined the security and
stability of many states
we underline therefore the importance of
appropriate management of weapons during
transfer storage and deployment
the UN has worked with member states to
support these efforts and establish
International standards
for example the UN office for
disarmament Affairs supports the program
of actions to prevent combat and
eradicate the illicit trade in small
arms and light weapons in all its
aspects and its International tracing
instrument
there are many other ongoing efforts to
establish International Norms with
respect to the manufacturer trade and
storage of weapons
we are encouraged by the U.N work to
this end
in addition to International cooperation
and standard setting constant constant
monitoring and oversight by national
authorities is critical and requires the
utmost attention
additional risks may arise in situation
of armed conflict and it is vital that
the relevant National authorities take
all appropriate measures to mitigate
such risks
enhancing cooperation including
information exchange and sharing of best
practices can help reduce such risks
Madam president
earlier this week we heard a briefing on
the humanitarian situation in Ukraine
it highlighted the civilians there the
coasts of conflict
to address these impacts we call upon
all parties to engage in diplomacy and
dialogue
we strongly welcome the agreement to
continue the Black Sea grain initiative
and commend the work of the UN and
turkey in this regard
this shows how much more there is to be
gained through peace and we stand ready
to support genuine efforts toward
dialogue to bring the war to adjust
sustainable and consistent with the U.N
Charter thank you madam president
thank you
and then president
I thank Mr EBU for his informative
briefing
last February
when this Council first met to discuss
the subject we noted that the increasing
emphasis on arms transfers in our
debates signaled in fact a dangerous
escalation of the conflict
this observation remains valid
the right of states to self-defense is a
fundamental principle of the UN Charter
however more than a year since the
beginning of the conflict the necessary
willingness to dialogue and the
abandonment of the illusion of military
victory
art is still not visible
only a negotiated solution can bring
about lasting peace
massive transfers of Highly little
weapons to the Battlefront can further
undermine prospects of for a peaceful
outcome
the increasing flow of weapons into the
conflict in Ukraine will only feel more
violence and will not contribute to
ending it
the presence of arms and ammunition in
large quantities tends to become a
destabilizing factor in the long term
compromising the chances of lasting
peace in the region and Beyond
Madam president Brazil shares concerns
about the risks of the diversion of arms
and ammunition the choices we presently
make must bear in mind the repercussions
and long-term consequences
significant worry
arises with regard to the proper
accounting of all dispatched weapons
particularly those that are lightweight
men portable and untraceable
the reasonable abundant evidence that
the uncontrolled supply of weapons in
Conflict areas can benefit criminals and
their risk groups even after a ceasefire
it should come as no surprise in the
near future if weapons directed to the
war in Ukraine resurface elsewhere in
the world being employed for malicious
purposes
we must also consider
the aftermath of conflicts there are no
shortage of examples of strong
paramilitary groups and militias that
retain possession of weapons and
capabilities originally intended for a
state leading to unforeseen and harmful
consequences
we must not underestimate the historical
precedence of these capabilities being
turned against against their original
providers
history demonstrates that when it comes
to transfer of weapons the probability
of the situation is spiraling out of
control is anything but insignificant
buried bearing this in mind Brazil as
party to the ATT
reminds the importance of this agreement
as a milestone in the efforts to
regulate conventional arms transfers
we urge its Estates parties to adopt
measures to ensure compliance with its
provisions and encourage other states to
adhere to the treaty or at least
considering applying its main guidelines
we believe that cooperation between
governments is the best way to regulate
and monitor arms transfers
let me end by reiterating our call for a
cessation of hostilities and the opening
of Peace negotiations based on the
principles of the UN Charter and giving
consideration to the security concerns
of all parties and I think
to Japan
I thank the deputy to high
representative Mr dejebo for his
briefing Madam president
almost 15 months passed since Russia's
aggression against Ukraine began it is
unfortunate to see the losses continue
to arise
Russia requested today's meeting to
discuss the issue of increasing supplies
of lethal weapons to Ukraine
any aspect of the war needs to be put in
the whole picture
this illegal and unprovoked War of
aggression against Ukraine was initiated
by Russia in the first place
and in this larger context concerns
about potential ramifications of the
influx of weapons must be taken into
account
and we must not misjudge the fundamental
cause
Russia has ripped three attempted to
divert public attention from its own
violations of the U.N Charter but we
must not confuse victims with
perpetrators
we underscore Ukraine's right of
self-defense to defend itself against
aggression
the International Community is lending
its support to Ukraine in order to stop
Russia's aggression and maintain
International Peace and security
on the contrary no Nation should support
the aggression
in this context we also strongly condemn
the transfer transfer of unmanned aerial
vehicles from Iran to Russia we would
support efforts by the U.N Secretariat
to investigate the potential usage of
Iranian drones by Russia in its war
against Ukraine in accordance with the
U.N security Council resolution 2231.
president
for as long as Russia continues to evade
accountability for its aggression the
International Community will repeat the
same contamination
Japan reiterates our condemnation of
Russia's aggression against Ukraine in
the strongest terms
Russia Master Israel all with troops and
military equipment from Ukraine and
respect Ukraine's Independence
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders I thank you
concentrations
obligations
foreign
negotiations
representative of Ukraine in this
meeting
until the security Council has taken
measures necessary to maintain
International Peace and security
and a quote
foreign
counter to international law or
International humanitarians
we are always concerned by the problems
for peace and security which are caused
by large-scale influxes weapons or
ammunition in any armed conflict
including risks of deviation propagation
and escalation
measures to counter such as
for post-conflict recovery and for
regional security and stability
inclusive and even also for the
prevention of conflicts on other
incontinence
for this reason we reiterate the need to
continue
increasing standards for marketing
registration and traceability of weapons
and ammunitions with a particular focus
on protecting civilians and the
objective of global stability above and
beyond any other logic around industry
production or distribution
we deploy the fact that the prolonged
Invasion into Ukraine's territory is
continuing to feed these risks at a time
of increasing global Military
expenditure which already exceeded two
billion dollars last year
of Civilian victims in Ukraine
I also recognize the vital role of some
defense materials and systems including
anti-aircraft systems which can
contribute to avoiding or just or
decreasing destruction
um infrastructure destruction and the
number of Civilian victims when they are
used in an appropriate ways
therefore focus on the need to guarantee
the protection of civilians and let's
take into account the obligation to
respect the principles of Distinction
proportionality and precautions
of any um
the Russian Federation bring an end to a
military occupation hostilities against
Ukraine we also reiterate our deeply
held belief in the continued validity of
the presidential statement it is 2022
of the sixth of May last year whereby
the council recalled that pursuant to
the Charter of the United Nations
have assumed an obligation to resolve
the international disputes by peaceful
means
strong support of the Secretary General
in Seeking a peace
in particular we recognize the efforts
of the Secretary General
move towards a peaceful resolution upon
the basis of the territorial integrity
and political independence of Ukraine
thank you very much
[Music]
president
I thank you for his presentation
that Russia has convened a meeting
devoted to weapons supplies to Ukraine
repeating this exercise
on the 16th of March
and the chaos will cease what does yeah
then we can move on to something else to
a fresh aggression
principles of our organizations
the
illegal use
on power relations
along with its Partners
to self-defense
strengthens Ukraine
The Invasion wants to be over in a
matter of days
has been held at Bay foreign
Russia is violating the resolutions
officers
and crimes
but it's only one possible outcome
in accordance with the charge of the
United Nations
that France supports the Ukrainian peace
plan
the representative of China
president
China has comprehensively expounded its
position on many occasions today I only
highlight three points first
constant feeding of weapons to the
battlefield will only lead to the
escalation aspect of the war and cause
more civilian casualties and more
displacement making it harder to start
peace negotiations in the hope of
ceasefire and cessation of war is even
more elusive
second
constant feeling of weapons to the
battlefield will cause serious
challenges to post
and bring about huge risk of
proliferation if diverted to terrorists
and armed groups these weapons are
likely to cause new turmoil in a wider
geographical area and claim more in this
and add additional burdens to post-war
reconstruction
and we have always been actively
promoting peace talks
into the Ukraine crisis
weapons to any party to the Ukraine
crisis
special representative for Eurasia
Affairs to visit Ukraine Poland France
Germany and Russia to engage with two
parties on the political solution to the
crisis
six African leaders men to visit Russia
and Ukraine shortly to promote ceasefire
and cessation of War crisis
thank you madam president
Mozambique
Madam President we thank the deputy to
the high representative of the
government Affairs
for his briefing
I acknowledge the presence in this
session of his Excellency the permanent
representative of Ukraine
as stated by our delegation when this
issue was addressed by the council in
February the trajectory of the conflict
between the Russian Federation
and the Ukraine is pointing towards that
prolonged War
regular public announcements of delivery
and deployment of armaments outside the
umbrella of the UN Arms Control
framework
Point towards further confrontation and
moving away from the escalation and
compromise
Mozambique is deeply worried and this
that this trend could lead to strategic
miscalculation and to an irreversible
widening of this conflict encompassing
Europe and the intervention of other
military defense pacts and alliances
as we stated in February the massive
deployment of arms and weapons by both
sides into an already raging military
confrontation is like adding fuel to
fire
Madam president
our considered opinion remains that the
prospect for peaceful settlement of this
conflict on one side and the increasing
supply of arms on other side are not
mutually comparable
we remain steadfast in our call for the
search of a diplomatic off-ramp to this
confrontation including the quick
re-establishment of Diplomat channels
and deployment of the good offices of
the Secretary General
we need to step back from the abyss of
war and from The Adventurous logic of a
military solution to the ongoing crisis
Madam president
the council cannot remain deadlocked and
Hostage to the mutual distrust resulting
from this conflict
despite the well-meant claims that equal
attention is being given to all the
global Christ hotspots the reality is
that this crisis remains a divisive
issue that is taking away resources and
bandwidth not only from this Council but
also from pressing humanitarian and
security responses to the immediate
other challenges confronting the
International Community
as we stressed on Monday during the
debate on the humanitarian situation in
Ukraine we strongly believe that peace
initiative put forward by its several
States including members of this Council
and African States should be given a
chance
political settlement is the right way to
address this crisis as a matter of
urgency
during mozambique's high level of open
debate on silencing the guns in Africa
his Excellency present Filipinos stated
that our experience has taught us that
only dialogue and Trust building can
break the trend of violence we must
resolve conflict through peaceful
diplomacy not resort to Arms
to conclude Madam president Mozambique
wishes to welcome yesterday's agreement
reached by Russia Ukraine and turkey
to extend the Black Sea grain Initiative
for an additional two months it is a
rare breakthrough
that should be capitalized on in the
spirit of constructive engagement
Mozambique therefore reiterates its call
on all parties to adhere
to Article 2 of the United Nations
Charter and settle their dispute and I
quote
by peaceful means in such a manner that
International Peace and security and
Justice are not indentured and of course
and I thank you Adam
and I also thank Mr Ibo for his briefing
449 days into the Russian federation's
illegal and full-scale War
Russia continues to attack Ukrainian
cities hospitals and schools its
civilian infrastructure
killing and injuring innocent families
in their homes or forcing them to flee
eight million people are now displaced
as a result of Russia's attacks
last night
for the ninth time this month
rain down another barrage of missiles on
Ukrainian cities
with a blatant disregard for human life
Russia is deploying more and more
powerful weapons
Russia sources weapons for Putin's
illegal War
from states such as Iran and dprk
in blatant violation of relevant
Security Council resolutions
the UK calls on other states not to
provide Russia with military assistance
president
we have repeatedly urged Russia to end
the war
withdraw
and respect Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
to cease attacks against civilians and
civilian infrastructure
and withdraw its troops from Ukraine
Ukraine did not want or provoke this war
the Ukrainian people want peace
but they face a choice
between taking up arms in self-defense
or annihilation
they have done so
in accordance with the UN Charter
we therefore support Ukraine to defend
its sovereignty and territorial
Integrity in line with the UN Charter
we share Ukraine's goal of securing
peace in line with the UN Charter
as my prime minister has made clear
we will continue to respond to Ukraine's
requests for the means to defend itself
against Russian aggression
last week we announced the provision of
Storm Shadow missiles to Ukraine
we've also provided a range of air
defense systems including amram
anti-aircraft missiles
these defensive weapons
can defeat Russian cruise missiles to
help Ukraine defend its skies and its
people from Russia's indiscriminate
attacks
the Russian delegate also mentioned you
depleted uranium
the British army has used depleted
uranium in its armor-piercing shells for
decades
it is a standard component and has
nothing to do with nuclear weapons or
capabilities
Russia knows this but is deliberately
trying to disinform
so I want to be in no doubt that we
provide all our military support to
Ukraine
in accordance with international law
and with robust measures in place to
prevent its illicit transfer
president
the cost of this war is felt around the
world
its impact on food and commodity prices
is severe
we welcome the continuation of the Black
Sea grain initiative
and call on Russia not to hold up the
movement of ships under the deal as a
pressure tactic
as U.N member states
we want to focus on other priorities
that the world desperately needs us to
work together on
such as delivery of the sustainable
development goals
instead
Russia's War has made those goals harder
to reach
in conclusion Madam president
I listen carefully to the Russian
delegation
they're trying to persuade the world not
to provide defensive support to Ukraine
the reason for this is blindingly
obvious
they want to overrun the Ukrainian
military as they have tried and failed
to do since February 2022
why
because they want to conquer a sovereign
country and Annex its territory
that is why the missiles are still
falling on Kiev
Russia can end this war at any time by
withdrawing its troops
until then
we will help Ukraine defend its
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and uphold the principles of the UN
Charter
thank you
representative
of the United States
thank you madam president
and I thank Mr Ebel for his uh detailed
briefing
We Gather again just weeks after
discussing the same topic and
unfortunately little has changed
we're here again listening to Russia's
allegations that arm shipments from the
United States and other countries
providing support to Ukraine in its
self-defense are the grave threat in the
Ukraine conflict and not Russia's
invasion of its Sovereign neighbor
it's a really interesting and I might
add Twisted narrative they choose
they're very much alone in this position
members of this Council the general
assembly and the Secretary General have
all repeatedly made clear
that Russia's invasion of Ukraine is a
violation of the U.N Charter and
Ukraine's territorial integrity
the United States has staunchly
supported Ukraine's right to defend
itself against Russia's brutal
unprovoked war of aggression
we along with 50 other states will
continue to do so
the provision of weapons for Ukraine's
territorial defense is not extending or
exacerbating this conflict rather
These Arms help repel Russia's invasion
of its neighbor and prevent an even
further invasion of Ukraine's Sovereign
territory
these armed shipments help prevent
Russia from further brutalizing Ukraine
civilians forcing them from their homes
and driving up energy and food costs
across Europe and around the world
armed shipments by the United States and
other friends of Ukraine are not the
cause of the continuation of Russia's
needless War
if Russia had any genuine desire for a
de-escalation it would simply withdraw
its troops and end its invasion
instead
underscoring its own hypocrisy
Russia brings topics such as this to the
security Council and blames others for
the death and destruction its aggression
is caused and is continuing to cause in
Ukraine
Russia is cynical enough to call for
this discussion while it continues to
relentlessly rain down missiles and
drone strikes on cities and critical
infrastructure killing civilians all in
the service of the kremlin's bloody land
grab in blatant violation of the U.N
Charter
we know that both Russia and Iran
violated U.N security Council resolution
when Iran transferred drones to Russia
Russia's use these drones to attack
Ukraine's critical infrastructure and
kill Ukrainian civilians
we know that in November 2022 the Wagner
group of vicious mercenary organization
working in coordination with the Kremlin
imported infantry rockets and missiles
from the dprk in violation of the UN
arms embargo on the dprk
moreover
senior Russian officials and the dprk
have been involved in additional
discussions aimed at Russia providing
the dprk Food and Commercial aircraft in
exchange for more than two dozen
different kinds of weapons and Munitions
in what would be further violations of
multiple resolutions of this Council
and just last week
the owner of the Wagner group was
calling openly for the transfer of more
shells and Munitions into Ukraine for
his troops to continue Russia's illegal
invasion
and yet Russia wants to talk about
support of Ukraine's self-defense as the
problem
once again Russia seeks to
instrumentalize this Council as yet
another platform for its ongoing
disinformation campaign
we must not and will not let them
the United States and others will not
end our support for Ukraine in the
exercise of its right of self-defense
doing so would only allow Russia's
unconscionable killing and injuring of
civilians to continue unchecked
accepting Russia's Brazen attempts to
redraw borders by force would tear up
the rule book that has made all of us
more secure
and it would have dangerous
repercussions around the world
instead we will continue to provide our
support
while working with Ukraine to maintain
the highest safeguards to ensure weapons
that we provide are not diverted into
unintended hands
we take the risks of diversion seriously
last year Administration unveiled a
strategy to help Ukraine and partners in
the region counter threats posed by
potential diversion of weapons in
Eastern Europe
we have stressed accountability from the
very beginning of the conflict
and have processes in place to
counter-illicit Diversion
Ukraine has been a transparent willing
partner throughout
by helping Ukraine a neighboring states
account for and Safeguard arms and
ammunition during transfer in storage
and when deployed strengthening border
management and Security in Ukraine in
neighboring states and building the
capacity of relevant government agencies
to deter detect and interdict illicit
trafficking of certain weapons we are
taking concrete steps to address threats
posed by such potential diversion
by supporting Ukraine and it's
self-defense
we are upholding the UN Charter
through its heinous actions in Ukraine
Russia is trying to drive a stake
through the heart of the charter
in this Council and at every opportunity
we will continue to State the obvious
Russia can end its war of aggression at
any time
Russia can end its Reliance on these
ineffectual attempts to distract us
Russia can simply remove its troops from
Ukraine's territory and stop its
Relentless bombardments of Ukraine
cities its people and its civilian
infrastructure
that is what we need to remain focused
on
until that happens
the United States will continue to
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
thank you madam president
IAL representative
of Malta I also thank the deputy to hire
representative for disarmament Affairs
for his briefing and I acknowledge the
participation of the permanent
representative of Ukraine in our meeting
today
today's meeting was requested by the
Russian Federation to condemn The
increased Supply increasing supply of
weapons to Ukraine we must remind
ourselves that this was Russia who
launched a full-scale Invasion Against
The Sovereign independent U.N member
State Ukraine has a legitimate right to
save the fence and Shrine in article 51
of the U.N Charter
today's briefing is another attempt by
Russia to distract the world from its
abhorrent actions in Ukraine by applying
that urgently needed and legitimate
support for Ukraine's Ukrainian
self-defense against an unprovoked war
of aggression is the threat to peace and
security
Russia created the circumstances in
which Ukraine is forced to defend itself
Russia began this war and it could end
it at any time by seizing its aggression
and withdrawing Russian troops and
military equipment from Ukraine's
internationally recognized borders
we are deeply concerned by recent
reports that Russia is seeking to
acquire weapons from dprk for use in his
war of aggression against Ukraine any
such deal would violate multiple U.N
security Council resolutions and
undermine the authority and integrity of
the security Council itself
we call on all states to refrain from
any arms transfer to Russia in light of
its ongoing illegal war of aggression
the result of Russia's aggression
against Ukraine is impacting nearly 18
million people not only in Ukraine but
all over the world
in doing so it has willfully violated
the rules-based international order
it has caused unimaginable suffering to
the Ukrainian population the human
rights monitoring mission in Ukraine
have concluded that Russia's strikes
targeting civilian energy and civilian
infrastructure are not only a violation
of international humanitarian law and
the war crime but also infringe on the
human rights on to security health work
education social support for persons
with disabilities and freedom of
religion or belief
women and girls are at the height at
heightened risk of sexual and
gender-based violence both in Ukraine
and while fleeing to safer areas across
borders
president the position of Malta which I
have consistently expressed during our
tenure in the Security Council is
principled and clear
Ukraine's sovereignty Independence and
territorial Integrity must be upheld we
cannot but note once again that Russia's
invasion is a violation of the U.N
Charter and international law
the situation of children Bears
highlighting the reported widespread
transfer and deportation of Ukrainian
children does not only violate
International humanitarian law but also
constitutes a war crime
Additionally the independence Commission
of inquiry has found that the
citizenship and family placement
measures Russia has instituted for
Ukrainian children by a violation of
their right to Identity we call on
Russia to immediately see these unlawful
policies and to facilitate children's
return to Ukraine we reiterate our full
support for mechanisms seeking to hold
perpetrators of these unlawful acts to
accounts
presidents multaria firms his commitment
to keep providing humanitarian support
to Ukraine and safeguarding its
population from indiscriminate attack in
line with the UN Charter the people of
Ukraine and millions around the world
continue to suffer from the continuation
of this unjustified and unprovoked War
in closing we therefore stress once
again the overwhelming necessity for a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine Malta also welcomes the
extension of the Black Sea Green
initiative which remains Paramount in
ensuring Global Food security we hope
that this agreement continues to provide
reliable agricultural exports and
alleviate Global Food Markets thank you
sovereign
foreign
[Music]
I thank you
of Ukraine well thank you madam
president
distinguished members of the security
Council
I also recognize the representative of
Putin's regime in the permanent seat of
the Soviet Union
when addressing the crimes of this
regime it is important to remember
that they derive from the genocidal
practices of Putin's predecessors in the
Kremlin
it is exactly today that we commemorate
the victims of one of the most
horrendous crimes of Stalin's regime
the attempt to exterminate
the Crimean Tata people
through Mass deportation from the native
land that started on May 18 1944.
the evil returned
in 2014
with the attempted attempted annexation
of Crimea
it has changed its symbols
but not its essence
if we do not stop the crimes of Putin's
regime
soon there will be no free dates in the
calendar
to commemorate
victims of all crimes committed
by Moscow
Madam president I thank director and
Deputy to high representative Abel for
his briefing
that exposed the baseless nature of the
Russian allegations
I'm also grateful to those members of
the security Council who have called a
spade a spade today
in relation to the Russian aggression
indeed when addressing this issue
it is enough to turn to Basics
to begin with article 51 of the UN
Charter that envisages
the inherent right of individual or
Collective self-defense
if an armed attack occurs against a
member state of the United Nations until
the security Council has taken measures
necessary to maintain International
Peace and security
to continue with the general assembly
resolution 34 30 33 14. of December
1974.
that defines aggression as the use of
Armed Force by a State against the
sovereignty territorial Integrity or
political independence of another state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the charter
to be followed by the general assembly
resolution
11-1 of the 2nd of March 2022 that
deploys in the strongest terms the
aggression by the Russian Federation
against Ukraine in violation of Article
2 of the charter as well as subsequent
emergency session resolutions
reiterating these provisions
to note also the order of the
international court of justice of the
16th of March 2022 that indicates as a
provisional measure that the Russian
Federation shall immediately suspend the
military operations that it commenced on
the 24th of February 2022 in the
territory of Ukraine
Ukraine will continue to exercise Its
Right of self-defense in strict
accordance with article 51 of the UN
Charter
we will continue to fight until every
Ukrainian Citizen and every parcel of
our Sovereign land are liberated and
Russia suffers military defeat in
Ukraine
we will continue to forge International
solidarity until all Russian war
criminals are held accountable
a formula for comprehensive just and
Lasting peace already exists
and its main element as follows from the
Anga resolution 11-6
of February 23 2023 is consistency with
the charter
including the principles of sovereign
equal equality and territorial Integrity
of states
if Russia is interested in surviving
he should clutch onto this resolution as
a live buoy and follow the path to peace
a charts
it is time for the Russian hordes to
withdraw from the occupied territories
of Ukraine
without any further delay
and not by cars stolen from the local
Ukrainian population
hundreds of thousands of illegal Russian
migrants should get out of Crimea and
back to Russia
where they came from
the Russia's criminal Banks
still has two options
either to surrender
or to repeat what happened in another
bunker on April the 30th 1945.
now the couple of lines in Russian
winners
because I don't have the goal to say
something that is high time for you to
do yourself
I quote
back across the 1991 borders get your
junk
and sling your hook
get back across the 1991 border
take to your Hills
before we drop you onto your knees
I thank the members of the security
Council and the Secretariat
Ely
Ukraine
in your blue dog